look you can just save yourself quoting
George Carlin's happens to be gay and
openly bits at me I know them so here we
go again doing sort of my monthly
talking about lgbtq+ representation in
media so firstly you can swap the look
out now I've actually had a few people
comment on the fact that I do this like
in a disparaging way not that they think
I look bad but like some people have
said that they they don't like that I
have to do this like they think I I'm
doing it to fulfill some obligation like
I'm not gonna be listened to if I don't
do this I don't think that's necessarily
the case but the reason I present this
way when I talk about these topics is
this is the headspace that I'm coming
from when I talk about this it's it's
fairly relevant to my point of view and
honestly I am more comfortable
presenting like this when I talk about
these sorts of things so yeah this is
what it's gonna be
so with that having been said this time
I want to talk about the funny kind of
balancing act that goes on when trying
to present a greater number of lgbtq+
characters in mainstream entertainment
in this case I I want to be clear by
mainstream I mean things like major film
franchises prominent comic book titles
well watched TV shows and in general
things intended to attract as many
consumers as possible I'm not talking
about niche work targeted specifically
at an lgbtq+
audience because something that comes up
a rather often in the comments sections
of videos where I talk about these sorts
of things is a plea to not have
characters be defined by their sexuality
or gender identity and what people
should be doing is to just write an
lgbtq+ character the same as you would
any other character and have them quote
just happen to be gay
now before I dig into this I do want to
say upfront there isn't anything
inherently wrong with this mentality as
an approach but I often see it presented
as if it's the ideal way if not the only
way to quote do it right and I do feel
there's a problem with that particular
outlook now I've talked about how films
TV or comics have they have to in some
way by dialogue or character action
confirm that a character is in fact
lgbtq+ because otherwise audiences won't
know they may suspect but it's hard to
be sure there are very few easily
identified visual signifiers of lgbtq+
unless we're dealing in clichés and
stereotypes and you know unless you're
doing that it does need to be pointed
out at least once so let's take it as a
given for the time being and assume that
happens to be gay as an approach isn't a
matter of never referencing but rather
of referencing it only to confirm it
most likely in passing and otherwise not
bringing it up and as I said there is
value in this it contributes to the
process of normalization where lgbtq+
people become demystified that air of I
don't know what these people are like
gets dispersed by having them in media
representations just present and come
across as being no different from
anybody else
to quote author Patricia Highsmith the
only difference between us and
heterosexuals is what we do in bed
except I don't actually believe that to
be true not for all of us for some
lgbtq+ people their status as such is
one of the major defining factors in the
directions their lives have taken and I
mean that well beyond who they choose to
have their relationships with many have
to deal with being ostracized go through
periods of deep personal
confusion and a lot of other experience
that simply would not have been part of
their lives had they been cisgender and
heterosexual and never questioned those
elements of themselves and to hardline
the message that lgbtq+ people are the
same as cisgender heterogeneity Q+
members of course in some ways the
pushing of the happens to be gay model
of representation is also an attempt to
counteract what is believed did perceive
to be a defined by sexuality or gender
identity issue that folks tend to bring
up often in the comments and when people
complain that a character is quote
defined by their queerness what they
generally actually mean is that
everything about that character appears
to tie back into the singular fact the
way they behave the way they dress what
they talk about etc it overwhelmingly
appears to be informed by whatever is
perceived to be the queer way to do
those things or as otherwise push
through a queer lens now I don't
generally like to make comparisons
between LGBTQ plus people and the
experience of non-white people and and
their experiences but in this case I am
gonna do that in order to illustrate
something and get to a point as clearly
and succinctly as I can now I'm about to
make some pretty broad generalizations
about the trends in media and the
entertainment industry over the past few
decades and but as broader than being
I'm hope it'll serve as a common frame
of reference now the term blaxploitation
is generally used to refer to a period
in the 1970s with a wave of films such
as sweet sweetback's badass song shaft
cleopatra jones also TV shows like The
Jeffersons good times
characters like huggie bear on Starsky
and Hutch there were books it was all
over the place so there was a marked
increase in the visibility of black
characters in the 70s however it could
also be said that they were there in
order to be as black as possible
they were defined by their blackness
blackness as defined by the pop culture
stereotyping of the time the result is
that yes there were more black people on
screen but they were pimps and hustlers
they talk jive and lived in bad
neighborhoods now in the 80s there was a
pushback to that not to say that it went
away entirely but rather that a
counter-narrative
began to take shape and that took the
form of characters who were black but
could have been portrayed by white
actors with little to no changes being
made to the characterization or the
story you know they happen to be black
this would include characters like
sergeant Murtaugh from Lethal Weapon
tubs on Miami Vice Lou agasa juniors
drill sergeant character and an officer
and a gentleman heck it's practically
the entire conceptual premise of The
Cosby Show which I know is something we
don't really like to talk about anymore
but it's kind of central to where I'm
going with this so apologies now on that
show
accepting occasional anecdotes from bill
or an older character there was very
little directly referencing how being
black affected the family's lives I mean
the show ultimately wasn't dissimilar
from fairly standard sitcoms of the era
in terms of premise and characters they
just happened to be black however this
then led to a new counter narrative
which was spurred on by black artists
and creators who looked at mass
entertainment things like The Cosby Show
saw more people that look like them but
those people were not showing lives that
were reflective of their own life
experiences as black people and I think
this is a big part of the reason that in
the 90s hip-hop began to truly dominate
and around that same time you saw things
like the films of Spike Lee really take
hold
gangsta culture in general and again to
reference a prominent sitcom contrast
Fresh Prince of bel-air with The Cosby
Show may Fresh Prince seems almost to be
born from the conceptual seed of what if
we put a real black
person in the middle of the Cosby House
and see what happens my point in
illustrating all this is that the
happens to be black period of the 80s
had value but it also undermined and
papered over harsh truths that were very
real for many black people and remain so
so to bring it back to lgbtq+ I would
actually argue
we've already had an exploitation period
at least as far as gay men specifically
are concerned other members of the
community it's a little later but saying
it with with gay men now the 2000 saw an
eruption of things like will in grey
square I have a straight guy queers folk
Brokeback Mountain Capote more talk
shows and reality show pictures than I
would ever care to catalog but by and
large they were there to be gay that was
the point of their presence flash
forward to now and we're in a bit more
of a happens to be gay counter-narrative
period and it's not hard to understand
why again it's mostly gay men who have
the most representation but male gayness
was capitalized on to the point of
irritation and something had to shift
and generally people recognize that
removing gay characters would be a
progressive step so the effort now is to
downplay that aspect of the characters
but I'm hopeful that soon will be ready
for the new counter narrative where
there isn't a definitive right way to
represent gay men or any LGBTQ plus
character and we can get a balance
between the characters who normalize
things and the ones who feel more
authentically rooted to the life
experience of many members of this
community even though their experiences
put them outside of what most mainstream
audiences choose to view as normal so as
I said people tend to say that a
character is defined by their queerness
as code for they just keep bringing it
up
and I'll acknowledge that yeah a
character having no contextual reason to
tie something back to their sexual or
gender orientation or identity but doing
so anyways is not exactly what we need
but I would like to see defined by
queerness to get re-examined for as
possible benefits I'm gonna cite one of
my own favorite examples
Batwoman now bad woman as a character
has been around since the 1950s but the
original version was wiped from
continuity during crisis on Infinite
Earths if you don't know what that is I
don't I don't really have the time to
explain basic it was an in continuity
reboot and besides it's not the original
version of the character that I want to
talk about here I'm talking about the
character of Kate Cain she was first
introduced in 2006 and she would go on
to take the mantle of bat woman and she
is a character explicitly defined by her
gayness and I'm not saying that because
she's had several notable girlfriends
and was even engaged during her time in
the comics all that's true but that's
not why she's defined by her gayness I
mean that not only would she be a
different person if she wasn't gay she
wouldn't even be bad woman if she wasn't
gay so for those of you who don't know
Kate's backstory her father was in the
military she idolized him she wished for
nothing more than to serve for the
betterment of those around her in the
same way that she saw him do she
enrolled in a military academy and just
shy of her graduation she was out at his
gay by another cadet now this is all
taking place during Don't Ask Don't Tell
where it was no longer permitted to ask
a current or prospective person you know
wanting to be in the service whether or
not they were gay however if evidence
that they were ever emerged it was still
grounds for dismissal Kate gets
confronted by her instructor who wants
to see her move forward and he says he
will disregard the accusation completely
not even look into it any further
because all he wants from her is just to
say that it isn't true and then he can
move on but because of her belief in the
principle she's been training and she
refuses to lie and she quits some time
later she would adopt the mantle of that
woman without seeking the approval of
any kind from Batman for the record
because she felt that the bat mantle was
a calling and one through which she
could serve and better her community in
a way that she had previously been
denied she wouldn't have become that
woman if she hadn't dropped out of the
military and she wouldn't have had to
drop out of the military
she wasn't gay being a lesbian defines
this character to her very core it has
shaped who she is and if she had been
written no different from a straight
character and just happened to be a
lesbian none of this would be the case
she'd have a completely different reason
for becoming that woman now more
recently I was very pleasantly surprised
to see something similar done very well
and the second season of Luke Cage on
Netflix now I was on actually a huge fan
of this season but there was a point
where two male characters were revealed
to have had a sexual relationship in
prison when they were there together
this isn't a toss off line it's not even
really a twist what it is is a reveal
that gave audience a deeper
understanding of these two characters
and gave us better insight and then
further informed their actions and their
choices in the series sadly characters
and relationships like this are the
exception especially in mainstream media
but I feel that this kind of approach
where examining and acknowledging how
being lgbtq+
has brought a character to where they
are and how they live and why they make
the choices that they do without having
acting gay be their purpose for existing
is what should be striven for
most often want to talk about these
topics there ends up being one or two
writers or aspiring writers who reach
out to me there in comments or in or by
email seeking for guidance on how to do
lgbtq+ representation right now part of
my point here is that there shouldn't be
any single way to do a write because
that would assume that all lgbtq+ people
and experiences can be represented with
a single approach and that's that's just
stupid
however for anyone seeking an example of
doing this well I encourage you to pick
up a copy of Batwoman elegy it's
available in trade and this isn't a
strict template that everyone must use
but it's a guide for playing out how
sexuality or gender identity
truly informs a character instead of
being a throwaway detail no more
important than the color of their eyes
and that's where I would like to see
things get because ultimately that's the
mark of any well-written character not
just lgbtq+ characters a well-developed
well-written character what that means
is you have looked at who they are
they're defining experiences they're
defining traits and looked at how that
informs them as a character the way they
behave the way they act and then play it
out across the story accordingly I think
where we get into trouble and then this
is kind of where that happened to be gay
thing comes in I think where we get into
trouble is when writers just write a
bunch of basically blank slates I don't
think you see it as much with main
characters but I think a lot of times
with supporting characters writers end
up writing a whole bunch of blank slates
they write their story and then they go
oh okay let's see I'll make that one a
woman and that one will be black that
one's gay that one's got a kid that
one's divorced you know they're they
start stamping traits onto them after
the fact and when you do that these
traits that you given them don't inform
the character they're just trivia so in
a way happens to be a gay is kind of
true you should write a gay queer
bisexual transgender character the same
way you would write any character but
the way that people tend to use it is
wrong because people use it by meaning
right just a generic character and stamp
a trade on them so that the trade
doesn't distract that's that's a shallow
character like by design this shallow
character the way you write a deep
character is by looking at the traits
you've given them and going okay how
does having this in their background
this is part of their experience this is
part of their character makeup how does
that impact the story I'm telling and
maybe it impacts a little maybe it
impacts a lot maybe depending on the
nature of the character maybe it doesn't
impact it at all but that's the level of
attention that needs to be paid for
lgbtq+ characters to be fully formed for
any character to be fully formed that is
what should be happening because
otherwise you've just written a bunch of
blank slates you Vijay you've need to
make a videogame comparison you've built
one character model just change the skin
and that's boring and uninteresting and
kind of lazy I mean it's not easy it's
work doing anything well is more work
you know writing a good story is work
writing good characters is work taking
into account the representation you're
putting out out into the world into your
creative projects is work and it's
exhausting and my my heart goes out to
anyone who makes the effort to do it so
those are my thoughts on LGBTQ
representation and sort of the finding
the balance between
to be gay like could have been
straightened you wouldn't you wouldn't
tell much difference or you know defined
by gayness which is often used in a
derogatory fashion I don't think it has
to be if you apply it right but it's
definitely like I I can't go back and
watch a lot of that stuff from the 2000s
I didn't even like it at the time but
what are your thoughts on all this
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments be respectful and let's
talk about it there's a whole bunch of
stuff you do there's like there's
buttons and there's like links down in
the description including one to my
patreon so check those out if you want
to find out more about what I do other
ways to follow me ways to support me etc
so that's it for this one folks remember
you are the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]